- This is why I produce content everyday.
You might be watching my content everyday
and it might be this conversation
with us in the vlog.
(woman laughs)
That's very meta.
This might've been the one,
this might've been the one, on this day
because of a conversation
you had last night,
because of the weather outside,
because of a news headline,
because of the patterns
of how the four Instagram
posts came in your feed,
it might just be the time you finally do
what the fuck you're supposed to do.
("Over the Hill" by Ian Post)
- [Woman] People like me
and my age without patience.
(music drowns out words)
- Right, right.
- [Woman] Like going
through or staying patient.
- I get it, I get it.
That's exactly right.
That's why I came up with
macro-patience, micro-speed.
Gotta go fast everyday,
you gotta go slow every year.
That fucks with people.
You're asking a different question.
You're asking when's the
time to jump in the pool.
When's the time to kiss the boy.
When's the time (laughs) to get married.
You're talking about when's the time
to take the training wheels off the bike.
When's the time to fuckin' live your life.
That's probably why I make content.
The answer is I don't know, nobody knows.
There's no right answer.
There's that moment in time.
- [Woman] Yeah, I see.
- This is why I produce content everyday.
You might be watching my content everyday
and it might be this conversation
with us in the vlog.
(woman laughs)
That's very meta.
This might've been the one,
this might've been the one, on this day
because of a conversation
you had last night,
because of the weather outside,
because of a news headline,
because of the patterns
of how the four Instagram
posts came in your feed,
it might just be the time you finally do
what the fuck you're supposed to do.
And I think a lot of
people think of it as like
quit your job and go
do your journey, right.
Things you're thinking about others.
I think of it a little bit different.
Sometimes it's
- [Woman] Impractical.
- That's exactly right.
Sometimes it's like,
I've been doing this night life
and T-shirt thing for seven years,
why don't I go work for something
smart for a year, reset.
Why don't I go travel.
Why don't I sell my home
that I don't use 90% of,
take that money, get an apartment,
and then do something with that money.
To me it's not just
like the fancy sizzle of
"Now, jump into the rest of your life."
It's also audit, understand what you need,
break up with that
person, marry that person,
start your career, go back
to corporate for an hour,
a.k.a. a year or two, to reset.
- [Woman] I see.
- Just do.
It's the indecisiveness
- [Woman] To make a decision.
- It's the indecisiveness
that is the poison.
Because you can always un-do.
- [Woman] Yeah, that's true.
- The biggest thing about
doing is the undoing
that people don't see.
I'm always like, "Okay, good."
And then if you fail, go back.
But people don't want the scarlet letter,
they don't want the judgment.
That's why you have to
tune everything out,
because if you go and
start your T-shirt brand
or your pin brand or your video blog
and it fails,
if you just think you can go back to it,
well that sounds cool.
But if you feel like,
"Oh but then everbody's
gonna clown on me."
If your pessimistic mom's who be like,
"See, I told you you could never do it."
If you can't get over that,
then you're fuckin' stuck.
- [Announcer] Gary Vaynerchuk!
(audience claps)
- You're not gonna change
evolution and technology,
you just need to figure out how to ride it
so it doesn't kill you.
And, by the way, I mean this,
I'm collecting the energy of the room
thinking about what we talked about here,
I mean this, I don't think it's bad
if you're not capable or
willing to up your game,
put in the work, hustle,
you should lose.
It's how you won.
But everybody fights hard for 30 years
and then wants to hold a, athletes.
You know what I hate about business
that I love about athletes?
When you're the best athlete in the world,
you get the results.
When you get to 36 and a younger
lion comes along, you lose.
In business we have this weird bullshit
that we're supposed to
be rewarded at the end.
Fuck you, I mean it.
Fuck you, you didn't fuckin'
take the internet serious
for the last 20 years,
why the fuck should you be rewarded?
Yeah, fuck.
(audience laughs)
That's the game, that's the game.
What, you should be
rewarded that you understood
some town was gonna be good
and you got a great 30 year lease
and you locked it in,
you got rewarded for that,
then why shouldn't you
be fuckin' not rewarded
for fuckin' completely
dismissing the internet
as this little thing.
It's the fuckin' world.
This is fake, this is secondary.
This is primary.
Eat it, live it, understand it.
That's the truth.
You don't like it?
Fuckin' deal with the ramifications.
You're gonna lose.
- [Taylor] Help Me Welcome Jordan Palmer,
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Thank you, Taylor.
Audio good, everyone hear me all right?
(Gary beatboxes)
- Beatbox.
Thank you so much, Gary,
thank you so much for
joining us, you know.
- Of course, man.
- We'll start with somebody
who's at a million,
somebody who's at 10 and
somebody who's at 50.
Depending on where they're at,
what's a piece of advice
you'd give to somebody
who's at the early stage of a million,
somebody's right in the middle,
and then somebody who's
really looking to scale.
- First of all, I think
to really answer honestly,
and it's a little more heady,
but it's the truth if I was sitting
with one of you right
now for five minutes,
I'd wanna know what are you trying to do.
What you're trying to accomplish
is just an unbelievably important part.
I think we get caught up in going
from one to five to five
to ten to ten to twenty to,
you get so caught up in the game.
It's the biggest reason
I think people are
struggling with social media,
literally people are pandering
to a "like" on an Instagram post,
not on, necessarily, what
they're trying to do.
So I think first and foremost, at a macro,
you need to understand
are you actually building
your business to sell it?
Because then you may care about the IBIDA
and how much profit you're making,
and so that advice is important.
Vayner Media is gonna do $170 million
and I'm not gonna make a penny.
I'm trying to pour it all back in,
literally, make zero profit this year,
and it's because I don't
want to sell it tomorrow
and I don't need the dividends
from the profits in a year
to change my lifestyle.
I mean this, it's really important,
you have to know what you're doing,
and why you're doing it.
By the way, you can change your mind.
You could be sitting here and be like,
"I'm gonna change the world."
You know, great, and if in two years
you wanna buy an island,
that's great, and everything in between.
So, first, what.
- Hey, Gary, my name's Johnny.
- [Gary] Hey, Johnny.
- A year ago, well I'm currently
actually still self-employed,
but a year ago I was self-employed.
I hated it.
I found your content.
I was suppressed and I
had a lot of excuses.
In the last year,
you have completely
changed the way I think.
I've gotten rid of all my excuses.
I'm actually in contention
for an internship here,
I don't even have it yet.
I'm 27, so I still got
three years to eat shit.
I just want you to know,
I legitimately appreciate
your content so much.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
- I'd rather be a number
one in a small pool,
than rather be number 13 in a big one.
- [Gary] Super fuckin' smart, brother.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome, brother,
that means a lot to me.
You know it's funny, I
really appreciate that
and I just wanna let you know,
one of the great things about
producing content everyday
and vlogging, is you stumble on shit.
What you, and I'm as emotional
about this as you are,
it's fucking crazy,
like we built entrepreneurship
up too much the other way,
we over-corrected and you've got a lot of,
everybody under fucking 25
thinks they need to be an entrepreneur.
The fact that that hit you, it's real man.
Man I wish, I almost wish I
was number 13 at Facebook.
It makes me super happy.
It's all about self-awareness.
My opening line was about self-awareness.
What are you up to?
Do you meet people, bro,
you know what my new one on this is,
because the reason I'm
emotional about this is,
man you got fuckin' trucks, too?
(audience laughs)
It's super powerful, I
think I'm also getting
a little bit more
emotional because that one,
you can't, I mean, look,
my life is so fucking awesome right now.
Do you know what it feels like
to get 20,000 messages a day
of, "You made my life better"?
It's just fuckin', I don't
even know how to almost,
it's almost difficult to comprehend.
I've got a new one that has
been really similar to that.
I know that it's going to work.
I know that there's so much opportunity
for people to become more self-aware
and figure themselves out,
and it's gonna help so much.
The new one I figured out is,
there's so many people that would be
so much happier making $27,000 less a year
and the only thing they have to do
is sell their current home
where they only use
18% of the home anyway.
Buy a home that has two less bedrooms
so they don't have to have the job
that is paying to maintain the lifestyle
that they've propped up for themselves,
and their life will be
disproportionately better.
I'm gonna fuckin' pound that content.
I'm gonna figure out some
clever way to really penetrate,
similar to "Close your
eyes until you're 29."
Shit that people remember.
I'm gonna fuckin' change
the game on this one,
'cause it's a big one.
Because there's a lot
more people living that.
As many entrepreneurs as there
are that should be employees,
there's way more people
that basically build a life
around how much they're earning,
get to a place where they hate
what they're doing to earn,
have the opportunity to still do something
that earns 20,000 less that they love,
but they're golden handcuffed
by worrying about what car they drive,
or where their house is,
because they actually care
about other people's opinions,
and nobody has the gear
to take a step backwards.
The inability to take a step back,
to take four steps forward in happiness
based on other people's opinions
of watching you take a step back,
blows my fuckin' face off.
(soothing electronic beats)